[Musique]
les vagues de l'océan atlantique les
rouges est inexorablement sur les plages
où ils viennent s'entasser sur des
centaines de mètres
des milliers de vêtements portait
autrefois chez nous en occident
finissent leur vie ici et polluent la
côte
jusque dans le centre d'accra la
capitale
c'est d'une artificielle ne cesse de
croître depuis 15 ans haute de 20 mètres
elle est en grande partie composée de
ses vêtements abandonnés devenu le coche
par les riverains
le gâteau regarde tout ça il n'y en a
pas besoin ça ne sert à rien
sous leurs pieds de vieux habits de
marques américaines ou européennes qui
affecte aujourd'hui leur santé
ça c'est un jeans de la marque boss
manager la regarde c'est un autre jean
des soins de tout ce que vous voyez le
tour ou non le brûlot
ou le brûle on encore et encore dames il
y en a toujours plus
ça nous rend malades ça donne de la
fièvre des maux de tête s'est beaucoup
d'autres choses les fumées de ces feux
sont probablement toxique même si aucune
étude scientifique n'a jamais été
réalisée ici
alors d'où viennent ces vêtements chaque
jour le pays en reçoit 160 tonnes par
bateau
ce sont en fait des vêtements usagés qui
ont été donnés à des associations en
europe ou aux états unis mais dont plus
personne ne veut dans les pays
développés des entreprises
internationales de recyclage les envoie
ici finir leur vie
sur le marché de canta mentaux ils sont
finalement revendue en vrac quelques
centimes du kilo
nous achetons des vêtements de seconde
main et ensuite nous les vendons c'est
pour ça qu'on est ici ça vient de
londres de dubaï du canada
au ghana toute une économie s'est
développé autour de ces fripes en haut
de l'échelle il y à des grossistes dans
cette boutique des dizaines de sacs
attendent de trouver preneur chevreuse
grèce à s'aider robe d'enfant
et là c'est pour les bébés ça c'est des
sous-vêtements pour hommes vous voyez
tout ce qui est ici c'est un gros
business dont je m'occupe de serbie
habituellement on reçoit ce à deux ou
trois fois par mois man twilight ensuite
les vêtements sont revendus par les
détaillants et chacun a sa spécialité
ici des chaussures là des soutiens gorge
le problème c'est que dans cette
montagne de fripes très peu sont
finalement encore utilisables cette
vendeuse vient d'acheter ce ballot de 55
kg
malheureusement pour elle à l'intérieur
c'est une déception
ça c'est poubelle ça aussi poubelle tout
ça ça ne
c'est cher vous voyez on ne peut pas le
vendre personne n'achète ça et à la fin
de la journée je suis perdante et donc
des montagnes de vêtements partent à la
décharge
plus de 70 tonnes sont jetés chaque jour
sur ce marché une catastrophe écologique
cette américaine a monté une fondation
pour tenter de comprendre l'impact de
cette pollution textile
voir que ses vêtements se confondent
avec la nature sacrée un désastre
environnemental
essayé de retirer sa du sable est
presque impossible
ça va prendre des années pour que ses
vêtements se dégrade et durant ce
processus des microfibres nocives des
toxines vont être libérées dans
l'environnement
pour cet ancien styliste new yorkaise
les marques occidentales sont
responsables de cette pollution mais les
consommateurs aussi
ce que les gens doivent comprendre c'est
que ces déchets rendre visible un
problème qui est dans l'eure est là car
nous devons prendre nos responsabilités
et changer notre mode de consommation
avec l'essor du prêt-à-porter bon marché
la durée de vie d'un vêtement ne cesse
de diminuer
chaque année c'est l'équivalent de 50
milliards de t-shirts qui sont jetés au
moins un sur huit échouera sur les
plages et dans les décharges africaine
[Musique]
et
m